first there are two elements in in in
motivation and rewards there is the
intrinsic motivation and the extrinsic
one right the focus in most of the
organization is about an extrinsic one
you know you get bonus right you sell
more you get more money the the problem
starts when you start to change strategy
or you launch a new product and then you
would like
to turn on a dime and and your
compensation program doesn't work this
is one thing the second thing is you
know people get used to their comp
and then it doesn't motivate them
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm joined by gal rimon
the founder and ceo of centrical an
employee-centric success platform using
advanced gamification personalized micro
learning and real-time employee
performance management holistically
ventricular helps companies help their
employees perform their best gal is a
mum graduate with an mba from tel aviv
kanati and previously was the ceo of
gilon a leading big data company which
was acquired by nest technologies
gal rimon welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you i'm great michelle nice to
meet you and uh it's a pleasure to be
here
it's a pleasure having you here as well
thank you very very much for taking the
time to to chat with me for 20 minutes
about your own journey and and more
specifically about
employee and this idea of
employee-centric success platform and
what whatever that means you know we
hear a lot about you know the the
importance of of the employee experience
and company and workplace and company
culture and the news but but this is
this wasn't always in the mainstream
media so i'm excited to hear about your
own journey as well as your journey
within centrical uh but you know prior
to that vice president within deloitte
ceo of gilon acquired by ness technology
senior vice president within ness and
now ceo and founder of centrocal and for
the past eight years so so quite an
incredible journey i would love to hear
a little bit about your career from your
eyes and you know how you how you see
the different stepping stones that
brought you to found this company and
then we'll dive a little bit deeper into
you know the the big pain point that you
came about to solve
sure so i think that my
foundation is an employee an exec an
executive was that i was uh a volleyball
volleyball player so
yeah so i was in the um
national team of israel the youth uh
team of israel
and uh i i think it built
a few foundations for my my career first
great you know you keep trying you keep
failing
second you know practicing and training
all the time you can't improve if you
will not invest
leadership you know and and uh
everything started there so today when i
i can give an example when i
try to raise money i failed so many
times until i succeed and and you know
other people usually say okay you know
i'll do a bootstrap or
quit right um but you know i kept doing
it until i succeed so this was my
cornerstone in the career
i love it i love it so as you venture
from
volleyball professional volleyball
player into the tech world
where's your mind at how do you position
yourself within this tech world and sort
of what is your north star in that
journey
so uh i i started in mamram you know one
of the israeli army technology units and
then the air force so i i was a
programmer so i have a very deep like
you right uh technical background and uh
it helped me always to start from the
bottom up you know to understand the
foundations of every everything that
i'm doing so
initially i i was a professional and and
then in during the years i
focused on bi analytics and big data
before it was
that hype
uh i reached you in an amazing hype and
and i remember when i started the new
startup ev everyone asked me is it on
big data
no it's new
uh so uh um as an employee i started as
a professional and then started to go to
managerial roles
and always the customer was in front of
me even in you know in the army i
remember
my customers in the air force and
i wanted them to succeed
and and then in every step of my career
i looked at the customer whether it was
an internal customer in the beginning
or an external customer and then it it
led me from this professional path to a
business and more commercial path and
then in executive leadership
right so tell me a little bit about
where
where you were at when you founded
censure call
how how did you see the world
and what how did you
sort of rigorously think through what
type of company you want to build
so i i had an amazing journey with a
company a big data company that i joined
not as a ceo but i later became the ceo
and helped them grow
by 10x during the years and and then you
know sell the company
and
the focus was bi analytics and big data
now
my challenge was that i always look at
what i call ut utilization of
intelligence so you bring to managers
insights and triggers and trends
and the problem is that
the utilization of their decisions you
know how many decisions they took and
implemented uh versus the number of
insights that you provided and and in my
experience it was very low and it
created the stress even when i was in in
my previous roles and then i wanted to
start solving it and this was the
you know small grain that around it i
started to crystallizing things so how
can we bring intelligence
and
create something that would be
actionable and will actually move the
needle
what are those things that then move the
needle that you've learned
you know over your eight years with
centripetal
so the first one was let's put the
employee at the center not the manager
but the employee the center because the
employee
is responsible on the moment of truth
with the customer i'm talking about
frontline employees but you know that
even i.t that they're not line they have
customers internal customers so everyone
after all having a customer and then
it's very important that every
individual
in a personalized fashion
would be aligned to the corporate goals
would know how to do it how to do it
well
would be engaged to to learn and and to
perform better will be heard right we'll
listen to them how to do things better
will be able to be coached by other
people and so on so after all if you
create this holistic and actionable
experience that everyone is focused on
accelerating their success
they will be successful as employees and
the organization will be of course
successful as right
now why is this not intuitive in your
eyes so now that you've been sort of
researching this and dissecting this for
for quite a while
why is this not an intuitive idea that
if you empower your employees to be
better they'll be better at their work
and at the end they'll be more customer
focused and at the end your whole
organization is going to succeed i
believe that there are two reasons
uh when we start talk about employee
engagement like you know
eight ten years ago
it was yeah engagement is like hr it's
something soft
well yeah i i think that again you know
you'll see an engaged uh
um agent when you have a problem with
your mobile phone right you understand
it they're engaged they try to help you
you'll be a loyal customer right or you
know you will buy something right so
engagement is the foundation of success
and results
the thing it's very very complicated
because people think that engagement is
about psychology that the employees are
you know
very unique and they are unique and
therefore the solution
to help engage motivate
uh align train and so on uh are so
complicated they they put so many
different um
perspectives and proficiencies from
psychology from data integration
from user experience and and business
and how to measure things how to train
things and and so on and then it's very
hard that you know a single company will
handle uh all of this complexity and
therefore until today
i couldn't find a single company that is
doing what we're doing
right so so tell me a little bit about
more tangibly the actual product that
you're developing with centrical and and
then how does that
integrate within companies to help them
be better
so centrical is actually um aligning the
employees to success which means that
first we
collect when they say we of course it's
like the customers using the platform uh
collect information and data from
operational systems that reflect the
performance of employees for example
point of sales right um crm systems uh
dialers every operational system that
start to reflect their performance of
the employees and in many many times
multiple different systems that are not
integrated and then and how do you deal
with the non-standardized you know
because the the huge problem here is
that you know you have this is not it's
not like you have a single score that is
going to be universal for all employees
to say this is how well you've done
you've closed the sale right right so we
we put
a few different
kpis key performance indicators or okrs
uh that reflects the performance of
employees and normalize
every kpi based on the performance of
the individual can give an example
um i just bought uh
a
goggles i started to swim and they have
augmented reality you know you see your
um you know lapse and and pace and and
uh
and and more information
so
the question is like who am i competing
against you know i started to swim and
and the other day there was like a 16
year old girl you know and i started
swimming in you know like fast pace and
and she was a professional you know like
dolphin right so so after five laps you
know i was
tired and she kept uh going so if i
would try to compare myself to her you
know that's it you know one time twice
right i would quit
i'm trying to compare myself against
myself against maybe people at my age
against my best swim in the last month
and
therefore i improved my performance in
more than 20
in two months right because i had the
best benchmarks
and therefore personalization that
creates that we normalize the
performance of every every individual
based on themselves
people like them maybe their team this
is the first thing to
build
uh unlike you know we talk about
gamification right get the first
gamification programs and platforms
failed
because everyone tried to put the top
ten
we have 1 000 employees 10 000 employees
the top 10 you know are
you know fraction
we have 990 losers right so let's make
everyone a hero
on their own game so this is like the
first step
i love it now in regards to this first
step how do you how do you get the
employees to buy into this how do you
get them to not just be okay with this
idea but to actually
want to go and and and take part in it
into and to dive deep into the numbers
into and to explore themselves
so in in my previous company right i was
the big brother right i helped the
managers to catch
the employees you know to catch the
problems to catch the
places that we can sell well or you know
provide
not not the best service here
it's all about you it's for you for your
success it's genuine
so this is the first thing
first thing the second one is
okay let's say that you fail right or
reach to your
feeling of performance
and now what right
and and then we try and to train you and
create personalized
training program for every individual
and again you know like the customers
are putting the training materials and
so on but our our ai analyze the
performance gaps and knowledge gaps and
then bring the next
best
training activity
micro micro training like two minutes
three minutes in in the swimming for
example it would be how to put my arm
into you know the water or like this the
the breath or you know like different
tiny elements that you break in order to
improve your performance and when you
tie
learning together with the performance
gaps you receive something unique and
something that you start to see that
help you to improve your performance and
i didn't even start to talk about
gamification
what is your key takeaway or a few
takeaways when you're looking at the the
way employees
improve improve on their own game right
so you know one of the big aha moments
it sounds like he had was this idea of
let's stop comparing ourselves to the
people next to us right let's compare to
ourselves and then find ways to micro
to to help us with micro trainings to
improve on our on our own habits what
are some other takeaways that you've had
about this idea of employee success or
putting the employees in the center of
their organization's success
there are two elements in in in
motivation and rewards there is the
intrinsic motivation and the extrinsic
one right the focus in most of the
organization is about an extrinsic one
you know you get bonus right you sell
more you get more money the the problem
starts when you start to change strategy
or you launch a new product and then you
would like
to turn on a dime and and your
compensation program doesn't work this
is one thing the second thing is you
know people get used to their comp
and then it doesn't motivate them
intrinsic motivation this is muslim
right uh you can't get enough you can't
get enough you want more and more you
know and it starts with first yourself
right and then there are intrinsic
elements that you know inc become a
company story accomplishment
uh completion
uh progression you know there are many
elements that that show that you're
progress think about you know like um
any any video game right you you
headshots
reach to number one and so on the second
thing is me in my
you know uh people that i care
my team my company my my center
and then there are first you know there
might be competitions but it could be
competition about like who improved the
best
right and this is different
and and then public recognition you know
um which i i just
in the morning i saw an amazing report
about a new module that we launched
around uh coaching
so
what was the most
popular coaching activity between
coaches that received managers that
received triggers on employees to the
employees
kudos
positive reinforcement using our system
over a correction action corrective
action and this is you know i saw that i
say
wow you know and then we compared
the
uh previous months for in the same
organization it was like 10
organizations and in in tens of
thousands of of people
and we compared the number of positive
reinforcement that the managers gave
before
and after we launched this uh solution
with the triggers
it was like i think five or ten times
more because it it was
objective you know so hey mikhail
improved their performance by 17
what to do great kudos and and then you
see you know like gal
every channel time was dropped what to
do you know let's let's you know uh put
him in a program or maybe shadow call
with with mikhail right and and then you
create something wonderful when you
bring both the employees and the manager
for the same purpose and not like
managers are chasing after the employees
but they are helping their employees
because the machine is finding the
relevant places to focus
and i love it so obviously now you're
working on something that is extremely
meaningful that also has an incredible
impact on on not just your own company
but but on on the companies that you
interact with and another aspect another
aspect don't forget who is the new
employee
it's the gen z you know the one that
everyone were talking about millennials
born to digital
um
gen z are even more sophisticated than
millennials right they have
the share economy how much a share a
like right uh a public you know selfie
right uh a world right uh second thing
games are are embedded you know like uh
everything around the game um i remember
when we started like in around 2013 2014
the game jar jargon was different than
today you know today
right because today you know the gamers
the millennials were gamers that now
they are managers before the x you know
the they weren't gamers i was a gamer
right but but most of the managers were
you know didn't talk the language and
today it's the same language
right right now as you're leading this
company and you know having to also
think about the vision in the future
where where do you gather your own
inspiration from where does your
inspiration stem from
uh the customers no doubt so we see
amazing things that the customer are
doing with centrical i can give an
example uh one of our you know one of
the biggest uh telecommunication
companies in the us
um during covid right in march they
needed to close the doors so you know to
the stores right
so
they with without our knowledge right
they created a new organization in 48
hours they
brought 10 000 employees to start
selling from the curbside put two chairs
and start selling on the curbside 1000
stores
all over the states right think how much
time it it it would take them during
covid right they can fly can send
trainers uh they can say you know as
many emails of like the operating system
the uh playbooks what to measure how to
measure they did it with centrical in 48
hours
when when i heard the story like a month
later
uh uh i i almost cried you know from
like my baby is usain bolt and and
um 2020 was their best year ever
and unbelievable this is great
i just love it hey girl thank you so so
much
i have one last question for you few
words that you would use to describe
yourself
huh
it's hard
uh i i think that uh
how do you say it uh
i think i'm a goat in a way you know i i
i i i'm sure it's it's unique right but
uh
it's also my sign
so
i like to climb and and whenever i climb
and reach to
success
i find that there is another mountain
and and i like to keep climbing so it's
very important to be at the top
i think that the road the climbing
itself to to you know to go to the next
level this is the the one thing that
keeps me running and you know not
finishing you know you don't need to
finish you need to accomplish and keep
accomplishing all the time and this is
the fun at work i love it i wanted to
say dolphin it's more sexy right or
something like that no no no no i'm
gonna go with gold i like the ghost yeah
yeah mountain mountain goat right not
not a goddess
god thank you very very much for the
time thank you thank you very much for
having and uh for leaving me
you know more energized than i came into
this conversation with so really thank
you and uh best of luck with centrical
and everything else that you that you'll
do after and then i'm sure that there's
going to be a lot and so thank you very
very much for the inspiration and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you mikhail it was a pleasure of
course
foreign